oh là là mais tout est si calme
aujourd'hui il n'y a personne pour me
répondre
giuly n'est pas là et prend soin il est
là en train de lire je vais lui faire
peur
je suis sûr qu'il va se mettre très en
colère mais ça ne fait rien à cacher je
suis bien content de ton temps de
casimir et j'étais en train de lire une
histoire de fantômes terrifiante et on a
beau savoir que ça n'existe pas on est
quand même soulagé d'entendre derrière
soi ils voient bien réelle mais n'a pas
eu peur non pourquoi tu cherchais à me
faire peur ouais magazine heroes qui me
concerne c'est raté et après avoir lu
une histoire aussi horrible plus rien ne
pourrait me faire peur tu chercheras une
autre victime dont je te laisse casimir
je vais rendre mon livre à la
bibliothèque de l'île aux enfants
salut salut c'est dommage
j'adore faire peur aux gens fait c'est
un de mes jeux préférés
il va falloir je trouve autre chose
quand j'y pense
s'il a eu peur d'une histoire de
fantômes
eh bien je réalise déguisés en fantômes
voilà justement monsieur du snop qui
arrive je vais vite me déguiser
pour toi bien il n'y a personne et julie
ni françois ne sont là à
j'ai fait tout ce trajet pour rien c'est
vraiment idiot tu as tant pis je vais
écrire un ou à françois puisqu'il m'a
demandé de lui chercher des
renseignements pour son étude sur les
fantômes
je vais lui laisser celui que j'ai
trouvé non cher françois
j'ai trouvé dans un livre le
renseignement
suivant les fantômes n'existe pas si
vous en rencontrez un n'ayez pas peur
c'est quelqu'un qui s'est déguisée
prenez un bâton taper dessus puis
enlever le droit
oui j'affine un fantôme waouh mais cela
est très intéressant ce fantôme a l'air
de très beaux spécimens je vais pouvoir
expérimenter le document que j'apportais
à françois monsieur le fantôme auriez
vous l'obligeance de venir un peu plus
près c'est beaucoup plus que ça tiens il
me semble reconnaître cette voix venue
un peu plus près soyez gentil mais je ne
peux pas c'est trop gentil je suis là un
effrayant quand on est bien effrayant
fanton prenez mais oui
casimir c'était toi oui mais qu'est ce
qui vous prend en panne
pour moi ce que vous m'avez donné des
coups de canne au lieu d'avoir peur mots
pour casimir mes ancêtres il ya cent ans
habitait un château en ecosse
alors je suis bien placé pour savoir que
les fantômes n'existe pas il n'y a
aucune raison d'avoir peur de quelqu'un
à cesson pour se mettre un drap sur la
tête et faire oh oh
alors si vous n'avez pas parlé mais
fantôme n'avait peur de rien
effectivement je n'ai peur de rien quoi
que je puisse craindre les voleurs bon
j'avais peur des voleurs mais vous
n'avez jamais un front turbo ou alors
pour kazim hier il n'y a pas que la
rejoue les objets et les vêtements que
je porte tout une valeur historique
inestimable
ah bon par exemple ce chapeau fabriquée
en italie avant qu'il ne soit offert par
mon père avait été portée par le cousin
de la femme le secrétaire de
l'ambassadeur d'italie au costaricain il
allait pas l'air pinacle je te prie de
ne pas faire de l'ironie mon prof
casimir bon mais tu vois je n'ai plus
besoin de finir ma lettre pour françois
il te suffira de lui dire ce que je fais
lorsque je rencontre un fantôme bon ben
c'est raté
j'aurai beaucoup mieux fait de me
déguiser en bandits au moins il aurait
eu peur ça va être l'heure de la tournée
du facteur
alors je vais courir me déguiser en
bandits c'est sûr qu'il va avoir une
peur terrible ça va être rigolo
il était temps le facteur ne va pas
tarder à arriver
j'aurais dû faire une de ses ports ça y
est je l'entends je me cachais et là je
suis un bon guide si tu es bon tu ne te
ferait pas de mal à mal du tout bah vous
aussi vous avez vu au cinéma échec ou
bandits masqués aaa qu'est ce que ce
serait
tiens vous parlez comme un de mes amis
enfin dans le film le cow boys écrit les
autres vêtements et les liens ou safari
oui mais voilà c'est comme ça à casimir
dans dans le film échec aux bandits
masqués au haut et je ne vous ai pas
fait peur pour surnom je sais très bien
qu'il n'ya pas un seul ben dis donc
toute l'île aux enfants et j'ai tout de
suite compris que c'était une blague et
une bonne phase aller à bientôt casimir
rien tant que ce n'est vraiment pas de
chance ne fait peur à personne et j'ai
mal partout
ce qui est terrible c'est que les gens
n'ont pas tous par de la même chose
moi par exemple dès que je suis seul
j'ai peur que karim a énormément soit un
bandit ou un fantôme voilà il ya plus
personne en jardin je commence
réellement à avoir peur s'il arrivait
vraiment un fantôme ou avant 10,1 n'y
aurait personne pour me défendre
pas pour tous
ça alors je n'avais jamais remarqué que
casimir était aussi peureux